en las aguas de la costa este de Estados Unidos.
En ese período,
las investigaciones concluyeron que las ballenas en peligro de esa región
contenían menores marcadores químicos de estrés en sus muestras de heces.
Como me dijo un investigador:
"Nosotros estábamos estresados, pero las ballenas, no".
Recuerden que hemos evolucionado como una especie visual,
dependemos de nuestros ojos,
pero la vida marina depende del sonido
igual que nosotros dependemos de la vista.
Para la vida marina un océano ruidoso
puede ser tan desconcertante y peligroso como para nosotros una densa niebla.
A veces eso significa mayor estrés
o pasar menos tiempo con los hijos.
Tal vez algunas especies se puedan adaptar.
Pero algunos investigadores temen
que para las especies en peligro de extinción,
el ruido pueda terminar de empujarlas al abismo.
Piensen, por ejemplo, en la ballenas asesinas del sur,
que habitan en las aguas de mi ciudad, Vancouver.
Quedan solo 75, tal vez 76 individuos en esta zona.
Se enfrentan a múltiples problemas:
hay contaminantes químicos en sus aguas
y se están quedando sin el salmón del que dependen para comer.
Y está el ruido.
Cuando estudiaron a estas y otras ballenas asesinas similares,
descubrieron que pasaban de 18 a 25 veces menos tiempo
alimentándose en presencia de un fuerte ruido de barco.
Y eso es muchísimo para una especie
que está luchando por encontrar suficiente alimento para sobrevivir.
Según los investigadores con los que hablé,
la buena noticia es se puede hacer algo relativamente fácil
respecto al ruido de los océanos.
Al contrario que los complejos problemas del cambio climático
y la acidificación del océano,
podemos bajar el volumen del ruido del océano
y observar el impacto casi de manera inmediata.
Por ejemplo, en 2017,
la Autoridad Portuaria Fraser de Vancouver
comenzó a pedir a los barcos que fueran más despacio
cuando atravesaban el estrecho de Haro,
donde las ballenas asesinas del sur se alimentan al final del verano.
Los barcos más lentos son más silenciosos.
Y como es Canadá, basta con pedirlo, es voluntario.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
En el experimento de 2017, casi todos los barcos obedecieron,
sumaron media hora a su trayecto
y redujeron el ruido en unos 1,2 decibelios
o 24 % de intensidad de ruido.
Este año han decidido ampliar la duración
y el área en la que solicitaban reducir la velocidad de los barcos,
así que esperemos que tenga un impacto positivo en esas ballenas.
En 2017, la Autoridad Portuaria Fraser de Vancouver
también introdujo descuentos en las cuotas de amarre
para barcos físicamente diseñados para ser más silenciosos.
Curiosamente, gran parte del ruido que genera un barco como este
lo producen las pequeñas burbujas de la parte trasera del propulsor,
así que simplemente se puede diseñar un barco que produzca menor cantidad
y que sea más silencioso.
La Organización Marítima Internacional ha publicado una enorme lista de maneras
en las que los barcos pueden ser más silenciosos.
También tiene el objetivo de reducir las emisiones de dióxido de carbono
del transporte marítimo internacional en un 50 % para 2050.
La buena noticia es que ambas cosas van de la mano.
En conjunto, un barco más eficiente es un barco más silencioso.
También se han inventado métodos más silenciosos
para clavar los grandes postes de las turbinas de viento, como esta,
y formas más amables de hacer sondeos sísmicos.
Hay incentivos para promover el uso de tecnologías más silenciosas.
La Unión Europea, por ejemplo,
tiene una directiva para promover un sistema marino saludable para 2020,
y una de las maneras en las que definen un sistema marino saludable
es en función del ruido que hay en el agua.
Pero en general, la mayor parte de las aguas no están reguladas
en lo que respecta al ruido del océano.
Pero la mayoría de los científicos con los que hablo
dicen que estamos viviendo un momento único
en términos de políticas que abordan este problema
y que pueden surtir efecto.
Sabemos lo suficiente como para afirmar que un mar silencioso es un mar más sano,
pero ahora los científicos se están afanando en conocer los detalles.
¿Cuánto más silencioso tiene que ser?
¿Cuáles son los mejores lugares para generar o preservar el silencio?
¿Cuál es la mejor manera de amortiguar nuestro ruido?
No intento decirles que el ruido
es el mayor problema medioambiental del planeta ni del océano,
pero el caso es que la humanidad causa muchos impactos
en nuestro sistema medioambiental.
Y estos impactos no actúan solos;
actúan en conjunto y se multiplican.
Así que incluso a aquellos que no son tan obvios,
hemos de prestarles atención.
Por último les voy a hablar de un experimento,
solo porque es precioso.
Rob Williams, uno de los investigadores de las ballenas asesinas del sur,
también trabaja en Bali.
Allí celebran una tradición hindú llamada nyepi, o el día del silencio.
Este día se observa estrictamente:
no hay aviones despegando del aeropuerto ni barcos pescando,
a los turistas se les lleva amablemente de las playas a sus hoteles.
Rob Williams introdujo hidrófonos en el agua
para medir el impacto,
y fue rotundo:
los niveles de sonido disminuyeron de 6 a 9 decibelios,
casi igual que en las aguas tras el 11-S.
Para un "prospector acústico" como Williams,
que es como se autodenomina,
el silencio es oro.
Junto con otros investigadores vuelve a ese lugar
y contempla lo que hacen los peces con todo ese silencio adicional.
(Suave burbujeo)
Me gusta pensar que están teniendo sus propias vacaciones,
dándose un festín y encontrando pareja,
celebrando su propio espacio de calma en un mundo habitualmente ruidoso.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)